we're really here we're really here
today to talk about an extra mortgage or
we thought this would be cool to see you
want to know yeah I'll tell you
something they've been rumors and I'll
tell you those rumors are true that Nick
Fury Sam Jackson is in this movie he
plays a big part in it and in this film
Nick Fury has two eyes what because this
film takes place before the events of
Iron Man 1 in his set in the early 1990s
and I'm telling one other thing for this
crowd it might be crickets in other
places but I think in this crowd the
villains of this will be the first MCU
appearance of the Skrulls
[Applause]
[Music]
we've got we have amazing directors and
a boat and rides like working on a card
and we can't wait to see one we saw him
sitting in a chair and Avengers
so I'm sitting in a chair and guardians
we saw him kind of putting on a glove
and it was time and I always said the
next time we show anything about fan OHS
it's gonna be standing up hey everybody
so they just made some really big
announcements about Captain Marvel the
Avengers movies and phase four villains
and what's going to be happening after
Thanos so I wanted to do a video for
that the Thor ticket giveaway still
going on all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this so you all heard Kevin
Feige teasing what's going on with the
scrolls in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
they're gonna be the big bad of the
Captain Marvel movie first and there's
an important reason for why Captain
Marvel is getting her movie between the
big Avengers sequels so you have
infinity war Thanos the Black Order
assembling the gems into the gauntlet
then easy said in that teaser Captain
Marvel will take place back in the 90s
so you'll like literally get a big
flashback movie that'll explain her
origin story how her powers work what
they changed about it it's largely going
to be based on the kree-skrull war which
I'll explain in a second then you jump
back to present-day you have Avengers 4
and Kevin Feige teased that they'll
explain why it is the Captain Marvel
doesn't show up til that movie she's
been out there and he like looked off
into outer space when he was saying that
so when he teases the Captain Marvel is
going to take place before the events of
Iron Man 1 because with a few exceptions
we haven't got a lot of history of the
MCU predating Iron Man I mean we have
the Captain America movie
we have ant-man's flashback Captain
Marvel will cover that period of history
in outer space it'll deal a little bit
with shield in the 90s so you just
imagine that ant-man scene right here
with Peggy Carter talking to the people
as Hank Pym is bailing on them Nick Fury
will have two eyes presumably he will
fight with her in outer space they
haven't fully explained how that's going
to go because Nick Fury did not mention
any of this at any point during any of
his encounters with the other Avengers
you just know that he lost an eye and
some serious [ __ ] went down before this
I think people assume that he just lost
it when he was in the Howling Commandos
before he became the director
of shield but sort of the other reason
for sandwich in Captain Marvel's
flashback movie between those two
Avengers movies is that it also sets up
the scrolls as a major galactic power so
they will continue to be a big problem
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it's
not like she's gonna eradicate every
single scroll before the events of
infinity war so they just announced that
Ben Mendelsohn is going to be the main
villain of the Captain Marvel movie I
think they're still signing contracts so
it's not absolutely confirmed yet but
most of you know him as director cranek
from rogue one he's been in a bunch of
big movies lately he's really blowing it
up but because I believe that Fox has
the rights to the super Skrull character
the actual main villain so to speak of
Captain Marvel will probably wind up
being the scroll Emperor whose name is
Emperor Doric so it sounds like that's
who he's going to be playing James
Gunn's sort of in another part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe still dealing
with guardians of the galaxy 3 right now
is also helping develop phase 4 space
based movies in the next 10 years of
Marvel movies after phase 3 is done so a
lot of the big stuff that'll be
happening in phase 4 like the big
overarching villains the stuff that the
Avengers movies will build to the
spin-off movies they do will be based on
new territory in outer space so you have
people like Adam warlock coming in
changing what we know of the map of the
galaxy a little bit like during Thor
Ragnarok we get to see a sacar it's on
the edge of the universe so it's just a
place that we've never been before the
Skrulls are just another example of that
but the kree-skrull war we got a taste
for the Kree during guardians of the
galaxy but we didn't know too much about
what was going on with the larger Wars
that they were involved with so for all
you hoping for Nova Corps all that stuff
that's where they'll get to that is
during phase 4 or phase 5 whatever comes
next because there are just so many
space based characters that are super
weird that they haven't had time to get
to yet that's where that will show up
remember Ronan the accuser during
guardians of the galaxy he was a fanatic
who wanted to avenge the atrocities
visited upon his family in the Kree
people during conflicts in the galaxy a
lot of that context will be provided by
the kree-skrull war because I think
they're going to use the scrolls as
the next version of Marvel space Nazis
and even though that term might remind
you of Red Skull yes he's in outer space
somewhere the tesseract just teleported
him somewhere at the end of the first
Captain America movie I don't expect
them to bring him back anytime soon Hugo
Weaving has said that he hasn't been
contacted but the funny thing about that
is that samuel l.jackson he flaps his
lips a lot when people are talking to
him he really likes to talk even though
he has absolutely no idea what's going
on is that his idea is that Nick Fury
isn't around right now in these later
movies like he hasn't showed up yet
because he's busy looking for Red Skull
which doesn't mean that he's getting
ready to show up they don't give them
scripts for anything even Tom Holland
doesn't get scripts for infinity war
when he shows up for each day's filming
they'll give him the pages that he's
doing that day but they're not gonna let
him leave with a script they don't trust
him that much just because he's a little
kid he accidentally took one of his
spider-man homecoming scripts home one
day to the place where he was living
while they were filming in Atlanta
instead of waiting to bring it back to
set the next day he actually burned it
so that he wouldn't get in trouble with
Marvel's security that's how hardcore
they are about this but again talking
about big phase 4 villains you get rid
of fan OHS you need something even
bigger so we still have Dormammu he'll
continue to be a big big problem as they
push out into more multiverse territory
in the movies they haven't quite got to
that yet but I think they've recognized
that a lot of their strengths are in
more identifiable human looking villains
so you have people like the squirrels
that are humanoid we have Ben Mendelsohn
who would be pretty easy to do motion
capture for him to make him look like
the squirrel Emperor you have people
like Cate Blanchett playing hella who is
probably the best Marvel villain
since Loki debuted I know there are a
lot of questions about her coming back
during the infinity war movies but I
can't talk too much about her without
getting into spoilers I will post my
thor ragnarok spoilery videos now
week I'll start doing Easter eggs post
credit videos but again you can see that
Marvel is opting for more identifiable
villains versus rings of trash in beams
of light in the sky but once you have a
chance to see Ragnarok let me know in
the comments how do you feel about the
way they treated her is a villain and as
a character versus somebody like
Dormammu in Doctor Strange even though
Dormammu is really cool I just feel like
Cate Blanchet the actress plus a
comic-book character he was a much more
entertaining movie going experience but
what's going to happen is is they just
announced some big stuff coming to the
flash they're doing a Rick and Morty
style episode with the council of ricks
so I'll do a video for that this weekend
stranger things also drop so I'll post
my non-spoilery review for that tonight
then I'll post some Easter eggs this
weekend so leave all your requests for
marble stuff in the comments below
congratulations to Matt 54 you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for my
non-spoilery thor ragnarok review and
you can click here for the last big
Justice League trailer and some early
reviews for that thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight